one of the great race hustlers of our
day in america is a man who calls
himself ibrahim x kendi
partly to give himself a sort of malcolm
x vibe
and um
he wrote a book called how to be an
anti-racist
which is very very popular book in
america it's flooded everywhere
there's also a very slightly less
grown-up version called anti-racist baby
which he explains among other things for
two-year-olds that you should talk to
your two-year-olds about the fact that
policies not people are the problem
i don't know if you ever met a
two-year-old but
they very rarely talk policy issues in
my view
my experience um anyhow abram makes
candy as he calls himself
says completely openly in how to be an
anti-racist i quoted in the book he says
uh the answer to past um
prejudice is present prejudice the
answer to past inequalities is present
inequalities you must you must you must
rectify historic wrongs by committing
wrongs in the present
is is his message what's wrong with them
what's wrong with that message
well
um first of all it's uh you punish
people
who look like people who did a bad thing
in the past
on behalf of people who look like people
to whom a bad thing was done
you're not even dealing with victim and
uh and oppressor
you're you're you're dealing with people
who look like perpetrators of the past
and people who look like victims of the
past so that's the first thing second
thing is it's not going to work
and i'll tell you one reason why it's
not going to work in particular which is
that um
that this would be very hard to do if
you're dealing with a minority group and
i think if you said to any minority
you're
you're really scummy and worthless and
historically you're the only people
who've ever done anything wrong and no
one else has and you know so on and you
should think badly of yourself and you
should be locked in this bad identity
forever and never get out of it
i think if you did that to a minority
group it'd be unlikely you could
persuade them into this mindset
try doing that with a majority group
i think you're doomed to fade i hope
they're doomed to fail i think they're
pretty confident they're doomed to
failure um i don't think it'll it'll
work but it seems like it's being pretty
widely accepted at the moment there
doesn't seem to be a massive amount of
pushback that's right um
i certainly get
you know when when you were
using examples earlier on of flipping
the language around to talk about black
rage or black tears or blackness that
you can't get rid of that makes me
cringe inside in a way that whiteness
doesn't
because i feel like it's i've just
become so used to
hearing that
terminology
use that
i don't think twice about it yeah well i
mean um uh
in the early 2000s the uh filmmaker
michael moore wrote a book called stupid
white man
which i reference in my book i remember
it very well i remember thinking even
then in 2000 or so
oh i'm not sure that michael moore could
write a book called stupid black man
uh where there's a chapter in his book
called blame whitey i wouldn't have
thought you could do the opposite as a
chapter if
mr moore
uh he he says in that book um
show me any problem in the world and i
can point you to white people being
behind it
uh
mr moore has not seen very much of the
world if he thinks that
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace